dos de los puntos que definen un cierto
cuadrilátero son 0934 el cuadrilátero
permanece igual tras una reflexión con
respecto a la línea igual a 3x dibuja y
clasifica el cuadrilátero muy bien te
recomiendo que detengas el vídeo e
intentes dibujar y clasificar el
cuadrilátero por ti mismo déjame empezar
dibujando estos dos puntos aquí en el
plano el primero es el punto 09 así que
tendremos que avanzar 0 en el eje x aquí
y subir hasta 9 sería este punto y el
segundo punto es el punto 3 4 y es decir
tenemos que avanzar 3 horizontalmente y
4 hacia arriba sería este punto de acá
además nos hablan acerca de la línea
igual a 3 - x así que déjame dibujarla
si le ponemos x igual a 0 nos quedaría
igual a 3 así que la recta pasa por este
punto de acá por el 0 3
y además tiene pendiente -1 entonces si
avanzamos uno hay que bajar uno si
avanzamos uno hay que bajar uno entonces
la recta se vería más o menos así a ver
si me queda derechita algo de este
estilo más o menos así ahí tenemos la
recta ok nos dicen que el cuadrilátero
permanece igual tras una reflexión con
respecto a la línea ya igual a 3 menos x
entonces los otros dos vértices deben
ser las reflexiones de estos vértices
que ya pusimos déjame empezar reflejando
este punto primero tenemos que bajar
perpendicularmente hacia la recta y como
ésta tenía pendiente menos 1 bajar
perpendicularmente es bajar n sobre esta
recta de pendiente 1 y luego tenemos que
recorrer un tramo igual hacia el otro
lado aquí fueron 3 diagonales de
cuadraditos entonces tendríamos que
llegar hasta acá hasta este punto
entonces esta es la reflexión de este
punto con respecto a la línea naranja y
de manera similar este punto rosa pues
para reflejar lo primero tenemos que
bajar
a la línea naranja proyectarlo y luego
recorrer una cantidad igual a lo que
bajamos aquí fueron dos diagonales
entonces acá también serían dos
diagonales saleh y entonces el
cuadrilátero que nos queda es el
siguiente deja cambio de herramienta
para que queden derechitos los segmentos
acá acá acá y acá donde observemos que
este segmento y este segmento son ambos
perpendiculares a la línea naranja y por
lo tanto son paralelos paralelos y por
lo tanto ahí ya nos queda un
cuadrilátero y como estos dos segmentos
son paralelos entonces es un trapecio lo
voy a apuntar por acá trapecio
muy bien entonces ahí está el dibujo del
cuadrilátero y la clasificación es que
es un trapecio